for as long as I can remember I've
always pretended to act like a gangster
[Music]
all these crybaby Democrats in the fake
news media call me the mobster president
like it's an insult but I love it so
there I was in the kitchen of an
old-school Italian restaurant trying to
find the secret passageway to some
Goodfellas so I could learn how to be
the greatest boss the world has ever
seen
could've been this way how the hell do I
get out of here I'm Donald Trump nice to
meet you finally I got a seat at the
table first you got Frank DiMaggio son
of an enforcer for the gal of crime
family Frankie was driving getaway cars
before he could walk then there was a
laundry list of zero
aka Boston Bob Luisi this guy ran
rackets up and down the eastern seaboard
last but not least Michael Francis aka
the yuppie done the FBI once called him
the most powerful and richest gangster
in the world I couldn't wait to hear
what these wise guys had to say mr.
president we hear we Manjot together you
understand we all eat I'm not talking
about food now
okay I want to try to tell you eat
doctor say we don't do it I'm gonna go
down I'm gonna need it alive
yeah want to be a go bottle enemies of
everybody around you buddy Democrats
Republicans everybody got to eat I can't
leave I've got a regular mix but isn't
it better to hire a bunch of people then
you don't pay them and then when they
see you you negotiate down the Ray oh
that's my would have had enough yield we
don't do that we don't do that that's
what I've done for you got a good boss
seriously
down in our life you won't last no we be
gone Oh God
I felt like a regular schnook
nevertheless I persistent so what else
do I need to work on oh maybe should be
a little a little key a little bit with
your tweeting I tweeted today that I'm
meeting again no vision really well more
tweets I got a twit Wow but I get so
angry and I got worked up and I go I
gotta say this right now you can't let
people know what you're thinking of them
now wait a min T v'n use emoticons no
not even the duty one with the eyes
nothing not even the doing nothing her
garbage
I got these you know what this means
garbage I love a fresh capiche capiche
mozzarella aluminum basil some tomato
and I forgot your role what did they
think I was funny I was a clown well
clowns are funny
I knew I had her in their respect I'm
worried he's got too many leaks in the
leg at least got a lot of these a big
issue this is we call me you know about
call me the FBI director well I just
think you talked to him but I saw well
the thing was I said listen you're gonna
lay off right
I just forgetting a layoff you know what
I'm saying I know I didn't get it at all
I think you should have fired him right
away
end up again it never trust the FBI
never trust never trust here that's the
first rule I can't stand the FBI the FBI
is a bunch of jerks you could tell he
was hanging out with his father local
friends yeah oh yeah who are some my
father's friends don't say we can't
share that daddy helps me out once again
we have so much in common my Python by
the zone so what else do I need is there
anything else that I need that I'm
missing you listen pay attention see
everything we do what's about famiglia
everything I think it's important to
keep your family close but what about
Melania what if I want a new wife Oh
you don't understand we were never
allowed to get divorced why me
are you kidding they don't divorce you
my life well how did years you know well
you have you tomorrow on the side better
surgical out on this look really
benefits I would benefit that's what you
gotta get so like my daughter what he's
it off shame on you
they think it's time to go that's go
ahead you all the way Scott I'm dying
having paid their respects they decided
to leave but for those four and a half
minutes we were King we think you will
good good you could tell he was hanging
out with throughout the Paulo amount say
- you know what else is made in America
me the dawn old Trump
[Music]